bonsoir le 7-8 l'aktu sûreté des fils 78
le journal de la rédaction en direct dès
18 heures chaque soir est l'invité de ce
30 janvier valérie pécresse bonsoir est
député ump de la 2e circonscription
secrétaire général délégué de l'ump chef
de file de l'opposition à la région
ile-de-france responsables de l'ump dans
le département on vous reçoit ce soir
pour réagir bien sûr à l'actualité est
locale et pio on évoquera forcément ce
dossier des municipales voici tout de
suite les titres en images les
principaux titres avec l inauguration
aujourd'hui est du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'équipement
ouvert depuis quelques jours va réunir
au cours de la soirée et sportifs
politiques personnalités soirée de gala
que vous allez vivre en partie dans un
instant l ump qui souhaite conforter sa
place de première formation politique
dans les yvelines lors des municipales
pourquoi pas s'imposer aussi dans des
communes de l'agglomération de 50 or l
ump ambitieuse nous en parlerons avec
notre invité et puis timothée c'est en
illinois de 22 mois il était en finale
du concours bébé cadum hier depuis 1925
cette marque organise ce rendez vous
plus ancien concours d'enfants vous
verrez qu'ils des onze lauréats
régionaux à remporter ce prix national
on commence par des images tournées à
mantes-la-jolie ce matin en déplacement
pour l'inauguration des locaux rénovés
de la caf la caisse d'allocations
familiales à la ministre déléguée
chargée à la famille a été interpellé
par des employés il lui reproche de ne
pas entendre leurs revendications
et ils étaient venus de l'ensemble du
département pour dénoncer hausse de la
charge de travail mauvaises conditions
d'accueil à des allocataires ou encore
plafonnement des salaires dominique
bertinotti elle préfère noter les
améliorations survenues ces derniers
mois et elle appelle les syndicats à
plus de propositions écouter mais nous
ce qu'on souhaite surtout dire madame
bertinotti mais qui ne recevra pas
aujourd'hui c'est tout simplement qu'on
veut bien d'accueil rénové on veut bien
des locaux tout neufs qu'on veut surtout
du personnel derrière les bureaux c'est
une initiative aussi qu'on a pris qui si
j'allais passer à la caf des yvelines de
réunir aujourd'hui de saint-quentin
demande de saint-germain-en-laye des
collègues qui viennent aujourd'hui dire
à la ministre ça suffit on peut plus
travailler comme ça voilà
on peut avoir toujours plus d'effectifs
on peut mettre toujours plus de moyens
c'est la solution je dirais la plus
facile aujourd'hui nous avons cette
exigence quand même nous sommes dans un
cadre budgétaire contraint de travailler
aussi bien voire même mieux et le fait
d'avoir de mettre du personnel là où
c'est le plus nécessaire
c'est ça que les syndicats doivent
défendre et plaidé et puis un social
encore l'annoncé de la suppression de
684 poste à poissy par psa des
reclassements sont attendus 400
intérimaires ont tout de même voir alors
contrat prendre fin à la fin du mois de
mars le constructeur automobile et qui a
annoncé aujourd'hui vouloir supprimer
une de ces deux équipes dédiées à la
production est de 7 208 prévisions de
production pour 2014 qui ne sont pas
bonnes selon la direction 40 % de baisse
par rapport à l'an dernier les syndicats
qui craignent de leur côté la fermeture
du site de poissy et la délocalisation
tout simplement de toute la production
est l'invité ce soir c'est donc valérie
pécresse présidente de l'ump dont les
élus les gemmois votre réaction à cette
situation ce climat social s'est
compliquée en france c'est compliqué
aussi on l'a vu dans les mêmes
sur la filière automobile vous savez que
nous les élus des yvelines ne nous
sommes énormément battu nous sommes même
battu à l'époque contre la région
socialistes d'ile-de-france qui ne
voulaient pas voter un plan d' aide à la
filière automobile parce que les verts
n'aimait pas l'automobile moi je crois
qu'aujourd'hui l'automobile c'est un
élément de l'identité de notre
département et on doit travailler à
l'automobile du futur et c'est pour ça
que je suis très fier que nous ayons
financer vous savez le pôle mauvais aux
mobilités du futur bien le conseil
général effectivement via via les tasses
et les investissements d'avenir de
nicolas sarkozy via le conseil général
et puis maintenant via les constructeurs
eux mêmes qui travaillent sur le
véhicule du futur il faut qu'on se
projette dans l'avenir faut qu'on innove
il faut qu'on travaille sur le véhicule
électrique pour renault il faut qu'on
travaille sur les nouveaux hybrides pour
peugeot c'est les voies de l'avenir et
je crois aussi qu'il faut baisser le
coût du travail et améliorer la
compétitivité de nos entreprises c'est
pour ça que j'ai dis chiche à françois
hollande baisser les charges des
entreprises pour qu'on continue à
produire en france c'est un enjeu
important dans le département
l'automobile le département d une qui
est le premier département concerné par
par ce secteur automobile on va changer
de sujet à présent pour évoquer
l'inauguration du vélodrome à montigny
le bretonneux c'est l'événement du jour
accessible depuis le 13 janvier avant
les portes ouvertes aussi de ce week end
pour le grand public soirée de prestige
prestige pardon ce jeudi soir dans
quelques heures si vous me suivez en
direct déjà sur place pour la rédaction
de tv fils anthony rech bonsoir anthony
les invités on l imagine pour cette
soirée se pressent déjà on précise aussi
qu'en plat de résistance il y aura un
france-angleterre un match sur la piste
olympique à attendre voyez tout à fait
les premiers spectateurs arrivent tout
juste dans les gradins de leur côté les
membres de l'équipe de france sur piste
ont commencé leur échauffement il ya
quelques minutes et juste à côté de moi
le champion du monde en titre du
kilomètre est le recordman du monde du
200 m en soit permis de construire
france 3 bonsoir tout d'abord ça fait
presque un mois que vous êtes installé
au vélodrome est ce que vous sentez déjà
les effets du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est un peu trop tôt pour le dire mais
je pense que les effets et on va bientôt
les voir puisque les champions du monde
dans ce mois et forcément cette piste-là
parfois c'est comme un vrai avant va
nous faire du bien mais on va très
rapidement s'apercevoir est alors sur
les méthodes d'entraînement on sait qu à
l'insep vous étiez un petit peu limité à
cause de la longueur de la piste ici
c'est une piste aux dimensions
olympiques là vous allez pouvoir vous
entraînez façon course oui c'est ça
c'est pour ça que le la piste second
plat était été construite on parle enfin
pouvoir optimiser nos bracket course
pascal idole c'était beaucoup trop court
on était vraiment trop et on
arrivait en championnat et à
l'entraînement les semaines avant on
n'avait même pas utiliser nos braquet de
course donc maintenant ça s'est terminé
c'est une très bonne chose maintenant on
a ce super outil et on va vraiment
pouvoir optimiser nos entraînements
allaient décrocher deux belles médailles
aux championnats du monde et aux jeux
olympiques est ce qu'on vous souhaite et
alors on sait que vous êtes installé
tout près d'ici vous en profitez pour
devenir unis montrent un veau aux
habitués à la vie saint-quentinoise oui
c'est très facile
je j'habite à un kilomètre de la piste
pas loin du centre commercial donc je
suis on peut dire qu'il y aura du
pétrole ici c'est super c'est pas
surpeuplée c'est c'est beau à voir
savoir garder des beaux bâtiments c'est
c'est
paysages et c'est du bâtiment assez
récent donc c'est un cadre de vie très
agréable mon collègue wilfried on
parlait tout à l'heure en plateau il ya
évidemment ce fameux remake de la finale
des jeux olympiques de 2012 ce soir vous
allez y participer dans cette finale par
équipe bis un petit peu ce remake il
faut les battre c'est anglais ce soir
non oui c'est prévu on est là pour ça on
va pas se laisser faire on est à
domicile ça qu'ils anglais c'est nos
adversaires les plus directs
depuis des années donc à moi
d'échappement que c'est très important
de montrer qui est le plus fort merci
beaucoup feront soit on vous laisse
retourner à votre échauffement et on
vous retrouve tout à l'heure sur la
piste de mon côté les épreuves
commencent un peu avant 19h justement
avec françois pervis et le keren
évidemment enclos de deux soirées en fin
de soirée le clou du spectacle ce remake
de la finale des jeux olympiques de 2012
par équipes entre la france noble de
france et la grande bretagne merci
anthony profitez bien évidemment du
spectacle on en reparlera dans notre
édition de demain vous découvrirez
toutes les images de cette soirée
d'inauguration du vélo grosse vélodrome
et puis ce goût particulier un de ce
france angleterre on se souvient que le
vélodrome faisait partie des structures
retenues dans le cadre de la candidature
de paris aux jo-2012 et que finalement
c'est londres qui l'avait emporté
valérie pécresse vous allez vous y
rendre on imagine bien à cette
inauguration après ce journal est ce que
ce vélodrome c'est d'ores et déjà un
succès ne serait ce que sur le choix de
la structure qui a été fait à celle d'un
partenariat public privé oui moi je suis
très heureuse de cette inauguration
parce que c'est l'aboutissement des
efforts de tous
et puis parce qu'on n'avait pas l'argent
pour le financer à l'époque où la
candidature de paris aux jeux olympiques
qui a été retoquée n'est pas l'argent et
on a décidé de manière un peu audacieuse
de faire un partenariat public privé et
je sais qu'aujourd'hui par idéologie la
région un certain nombre de
collectivités de gauche refusent de
financer des partenariats public privé
or là et bien là ville nouvelle de saint
quentin la région ile de france et
l'état ont fait un magnifique
partenariat avec le secteur privé qui
nous permet à moindre coût d'avoir eu
cet équipement et de la voir et surtout
entendre parce que très souvent vous
savez quand c'est l'état qui finance ou
quand ces collectivités publiques qui a
des retard dans l'achèvement des travaux
le partenariat public privé à ce marché
avec bouygues bâtiment notamment
ile-de-france et ses vélos police qui va
donc gérer une exploitation et
maintenance du site pendant 30 ans
investissement de 74 millions d'euros 53
millions financé par l'état la région
ile-de-france encore le conseil général
et la communauté d'agglomération si je
vous ai posé cette question et vous avez
un petit peu commencé à y répondre au
tour des partenariats public-privé et
privé c'est aussi parce que en ce moment
ils sont pointés du doigt notamment par
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines qui connaît de graves
difficultés financières aujourd'hui on
est que vous explique que finalement ça
coûte cher et que ses chefs d'entreprise
que sont devenus ces présidents
d'université non pas forcément gérée
comme une fallait ces partenariats
public privé ils n'ont pas été assez
encadré ce qu'il fallait aussi voir les
modalités différemment pour les ppp
comment vous analysez les choses
aujourd'hui alors d'abord il faut dire
que l'autonomie donnée aux universités
c'est évidemment la liberté de faire des
choix mais c'est aussi la responsabilité
d'un budget et donc il est évident que
les nouveaux présidents d'universités
autonomes doivent s'entourer de
compétences mais à l'époque lorsque vous
étiez ministre lorsque nicolas sarkozy
on a fait une mesure phare de son
quinquennat cette loi d'autonomie est ce
que vous avez donné suffisamment de clé
à ses présidents d'université pour qu'il
gère au mieux ensuite en tant que bon
chef d'entreprise l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin si je ne me
trompe pas et passer à l'autonomie en
2010 c'est effectivement à l'époque nous
donnions ce qu'on appelle un package
automne au mystère des moyens pour
recruter et personnel qualifié et des
moyens pour faire de la formation de ses
personnels moi je ne sais pas ce qui
s'est passé à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin je sais qu'il
ya une enquête en cours pour le
déterminer un audit je sais qu'il ya eu
des erreurs de gestion qui
malheureusement aujourd'hui ont creusé
un trou dans les finances de
l'université par exemple la livraison de
l'amphi de médecine on n'aurait pas mis
dans le budget le coût du chauffage et
de l'entretien des bâtiments enfin ça
c'est une erreur de gestion mafieuse
d'un partenariat public-privé d'ailleurs
oui mais c'est pas le partenariat qui
est en cause sur le partenariat a permis
de faire un magnifique enfile médecine
le problème c'est que après il faut
l'entretenir il donc il faut mettre dans
le budget l'argent pour l'entretenir
donc il ya eu un certain nombre de
défaillances de gestion il ya eu aussi
le succès de cette université il faut le
dire et personne n'en pas cette
université marche très bien et on
parlait de chercheur de l'université
aujourd'hui on parle de ce oui mais ces
succès ce n'est pas la seule université
qui rend compte des attentes et où il
met les autres cd chaque cas est un cas
différent l'université de versailles
saint quentin et universités qui
rencontre un grand succès en matière de
recherche et en matière d'enseignement
parce que elle a une équipe pédagogique
extrêmement dynamique et des jeunes
chercheurs extrêmement tonique dans le
domaine de la climatologie de la chimie
mais ce qui est important c'est que
quand on a cette dynamique il faut aussi
qu'on soit accompagnée à la hauteur de
cette dynamique parce que évidemment si
vous avez plus d'étudiants vous avez
plus de besoins financiers donc je pense
que ce qui s'était laisse copé dans
l'université de versailles saint quentin
c'est effectivement une équipe qui avait
peut-être des faiblesses en matière de
gestion et puis aussi universités
victime de son succès parce que les
universités de banlieue sont sous dotées
elles sont sous financés j'avais essayé
de rééquilibrer les finances au profit
des universités peut-être que le
mouvement ne s'est pas poursuivie parce
que je sais que françois hollande a été
obligé de faire des économies mais je t
aime la compagnie 2 rien merci à
l'époque l'accompagnement vous n'y êtes
pas dit à un moment on va aller lancer
dans l'autonomie c'est les chefs
d'entreprise que deviennent donc ces
présidents d'université ont pas des
chefs d'entreprise m'arrêter de par les
chefs d'entreprise il s'exprime comme
des chefs d'entreprise ils doivent le
gérer comme des chefs d'entreprise
algériens marchent devant gérer des
budgets non non c'est pas des chefs
d'entreprise des chefs d'entreprise de
faire du profit ce qu'on demande à des
chefs à des présidents d'université
c'est d'avoir une stratégie pédagogique
et de formation et de s'entourer d'un
directeur général qui sache gérer
l'argent à l'époque qu'ils accèdent à la
succession des présidents
d'établissement public comme on a des
présidents musée ou comme on a des
présidents de deux tablissements public
château de versailles est un
établissement public et aujourd'hui on
nous dit tous ne sont pas compétents et
sait on jamais dû recevoir sa jolie dit
jeudi que visiblement dans lequel de
l'université de 50 ans c'est ce que
disent les enquêtes il y a eu des
erreurs de gestion qui ont été commises
on peut tout mettre sur le la
responsabilité du ministère mais je
rappelle le principe de l'autonomie
quand on demande l'autonomie c'est qu'on
s'estime capable de gérer et les
présidents d'université nous ont demandé
de ne leur laisser
la liberté de gérer donc c'est facile
après de dire je vous ai demandé la
liberté mais j'aurais préféré que
finalement vous nous tenir en laisse et
sous tutelle moi j'avais proposé aux
présidents d'université à l'époque du
début de l'autonomie un partenariat où
le directeur des finances publiques
départementales puisse contrôler leurs
dépenses pour les aider à parfaire des
dépenses des dépenses mauvaise ils m'ont
dit non surtout pas vous ne pouvez pas
nous reprendre d'une main l'autonomie
que nous avait donné ils ont demandé
l'autonomie ils ont eu si certains ont
fait des erreurs de gestion elles n'ont
peut-être pas été décelé à temps et si
elles n'ont pas été déçues l'attend ça
n'est pas la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement qui n'était plus aux
manettes vous étiez ministre à l'époque
de l'autonome non non je t'ai mise
l'autonomie quand l'univers c'est
versailles saint quentin est passé à la
suite d'un audit et je leur ai proposé
des moyens pour pour gérer cette
autonomie si à partir de 2012 les choses
se sont mal passées m de 2011 je n'étais
plus aux commandes en tout cas pour
revenir au vélodrome l'inauguration de
ce soir ne fera pas que des heureux le
centre national du cyclisme français
fait toujours débat pour certains
habitants de montigny le bretonneux qui
ne veulent pas être oubliés dans leur
combat anthony rech pour les précisions
3,7 millions d'euros c'est la somme que
réclame la société vélopolis à neuf
habitants de montigny le bretonneux a
signé suite alors recours déposé en 2010
contre le permis de construire du
vélodrome et le plan local d'urbanisme
certains signes montrent un ont
récemment arrêté leur combat clairement
demandé 3 7 millions d'euros à neuf
personnes neuf citoyens qui ont
simplement déposé un recours contre le
permis de construire contrôle p lus
c'est vraiment une manoeuvre
d'intimidation
d'ailleurs trois d'entre eux n'ont pas
supporté la pression que suppose cette
intimidation et donc se sont retirés
initialement prévue le 21 janvier
l'audience a pour l'instant été reporté
selon l'association le financement du
projet risque de mettre en difficulté
financière la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce que le
vélodrome a été fait dans le cadre d'un
partenariat public privé
qui est un gouffre financier qui était
très à la mode il ya quelques années sur
lequel toutes les collectivités
territoriales sont en train de revenir
parce que c'est une façon d'avoir de
l'argent rapidement mais qui à long
terme est vraiment quelque chose qui va
en paix amputer leurs finances pour les
assigner de montigny les millions
investis dont le vélodrome ont empêché
la réalisation d'autres projets ils
inaugureront symboliquement une non
piste cyclabe au bord de la nationale 10
sur la commune de trappes ce samedi 1er
février
durant les prochaines minutes nous
allons à présent à évoquer les
municipales aborder ce dossier vous avez
annoncé valérie pécresse en fin de
semaine dernière un accord que vous
qualifier d'historique avec les
centristes de l'udf alliance dans les
villes autour de candidature commune
tout semble aller pour le mieux sauf
forcément à maurepas on va redonner le
contexte de maurepas même si on en parle
souvent sur cette antenne pierre
leguérinel candidats udi sollicite aussi
l'investiture ump ça ne plaît pas
visiblement à l'ensemble de votre
famille politique et pire le guérinel on
le rappelle était et alliés à georges
mougeot le divers-gauche maire sortant
il a ensuite d'ailleurs démissionné pour
mener sa campagne au nom de l'ue dei et
puis il ya un nouveau candidat grégory
guerre et astier il reçoit dans un
premier temps l'investiture ump mais
aujourd'hui vous dit stop il faut une
seule liste où on retire notre soutien
c'est ça oui aujourd'hui tout indique si
on nous reparle que si lui dénier l'ump
est faut l'union avant le premier tour
nous avons de bonnes chances de
provoquer l'alternance est un nouveau
projet pour sa peau quand vous n'avez
pas les mettre d'accord et bien vous
savez des semaines la politique n'est
jamais simple le problème de maurepas et
on le connaît ça fait des décennies
qu'il ya des des querelles et des
guerres au sein de la droite et les
divisions sein de la droite et du centre
mort d'asia et avec un os richard le
président de l'ue dit nous allons
provoquer une réunion des deux listes
pour essayer de trouver des voies de
l'union au premier tour de préférence au
second tour si on n'y arrive pas mais
vraiment ça me permet de passer un
message à tous les yvelinois qui nous
écoutent l'union fait la force et nos
électeurs ne supporte plus le spectacle
de nos divisions je le sais j'en ai moi
même été
disons la victime dans la guerre des
chefs à l'ump qui a laissé une
impression je le comprends tout à fait
déplorable à l'ensemble des français il
se battait en or quoi ça mord pas c'est
pas déjà trop tard et rien ni trop tard
moi je pense qu'avec deux candidats
s'opposent véritablement c'est
normalement aussi c'est vrai mais les
français sont capables de comprendre
qu'on puisse à un moment donné faire
l'union une union un mariage de raison
parce qu'on veut ensemble porter un
autre projet pour une magnifique ville
comme mourrez vous parlez d'un mariage
de raison pour autant d'introduction
vous nous avez dit si on arrive à
s'allier on arrivera à gagner donc ces
deux raisons pour développer la ville où
c'est surtout par intérêt pour remporter
une nouvelle supplémentaire pour la
droite c'est parce que aujourd'hui ce
qui nous importe c'est la succession de
monsieur mougeot et cette succession de
monsieur jojo est un moment charnière
pour la ville de maurepas et on voit
bien que et si on regarde la gestion de
la droite et du centre dans le
département on voit bien le label de
qualité qui lie à avoir un maire de la
droite et du centre dans les yvelines on
voit bien qu'à maire de la droite et du
centre gère de manière économe les
finances qu'il n'augmente pas les impôts
qu'il fait de la qualité de vie qui le
construit en général du beau que enfin
ils gèrent ces services publics de façon
à ce qu'il soit efficace mais peu
coûteux on voit bien qu'il ya un label
de qualité de la gestion de droite dans
les yvelines et je crois que ce label de
qualité là nous pouvons le faire valoir
amour pas à condition de ne pas donner
les noms des indivisions d'où vient le
blocage aujourd'hui il semble plutôt
qu'ils viennent du côté de grégory des
restrictions des coups de pierres le
guérinel pour lui d il nous dit moi je
suis prêt l'union il n'y a pas de soucis
grégory guerre et astier dit quels que
soient les termes de l'union je n'en
veux pas je ne veux pas en entendre
parler non c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué que ça vous le savez bien le
problème après c'est les personnes la
question c'est qui en tête de liste
alors général de gaulle avait l'habitude
de dire et c'est franck borotra qui le
citait il avait l'habitude de dire les
ambitions personnelles sont des passions
enfantine alors je n'irai pas jusque là
mais je pense que de temps en temps il
faut renoncer à son ambition personnelle
pour porter un projet de ville un projet
qui vous dépasse et un projet dans
l'union c'est un message que vous
adressez à gré lors il est resté très
calme message que j'adresse à pierre
leguérinel et adri d'auriga restiez et
que nous irons partout le garage à la
personne finalement que non et pourquoi
se fâcher puisque nous voulons
aujourd'hui porter ensemble en projet il
y aura des conséquences
grégory est resté par exemple pourrait
se voir non seulement retirer
l'investiture et en plus être exclu de
l'ump je crois que n'ai pas compris ce
que je vous disais j'essaye de marjah où
c'est essayer de marier mais c'est un
mariage difficile mariage contre nature
nous avons dit nous avons dit que nous
lui que nous donnerions une investiture
commune ou pas d'investiture du tout et
je crois que les électeurs de maurepas
comprennent que en tout cas la tête de
l'ump à la tête de l'udps et des idées
il y a des présidents qui veulent
l'union je crois que c'est ça qu'ils
attendent de nous on quitte maurepas on
quitte lui dit d'autres accords d'autres
négociations éventuellement avec le
modem cette fois ci est ce que vous
discutez avec le modem dans le
département et le modem des yvelines
c'est très compliqué parce que ils n'ont
pas de politique au niveau du
département donc il y a des modems sur
des listes de droite très peu et puis il
y a beaucoup de modem sur des listes de
gauche et dans des villes qui sont pour
nous des villes sensibles je pense à
plaisir à villepreux oakley qui sont
trois villes qui sont très importantes
pour pour la droite et le centre
yvelinois donc je crois que dans ces
villes sociologiquement sensibles qui
sont importantes et bien le fait que le
modem est choisi d'aller s'allier à la
gauche empêche toute négociation le
modem 9 hrs ne figura sur aucune des
listes ump si bien sûr que si
on met souvent là ça n'est pas une
négociation départemental à ce moment là
c'est des négociations entre personnes
avec des logiques locales mais la vérité
c'est que la stratégie du modem évinois
et très peu lisible on n'a toujours pas
compris dans les yvelines si le modem
voter à gauche ou s'il voter à droite
c'est un vrai sujet pour nous on évoqué
la naissance pour les électeurs
n'évoquer d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines est ce que
vous voyez la droite l'emporté on
imagine que ce bastion de gauche au
milieu d'un département très à droite
doit finir quand même par vous agacer
non mais ce qui nous a agacé c'est la
stratégie de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines du repli sur soi
l'agglomération est formidablement riche
et a un potentiel extraordinaire
elle a refusé dans le cadre des
intercommunalités d'accepter plaisir les
clés et villepreux qui souhaitait
rentrer dans la casse qui elle a refusé
de s'ouvrir éventuellement aux demandes
de ville de la vallée de chevreuse qui
aurait voulu elle aussi être associé à
cette richesse donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le problème de la ville
elle de saint-quentin vu de ses voisins
c'est que c'est un peu les privilégiés
chez eux et il ya une vie une gestion
qui est très peu ouverte sur le reste du
département ça c'est dommageable parce
que je pense qu'il y aurait une vraie
complémentarité à avoir au sein de la
caisse qui une zone urbaine et puis une
zone plus rurale un poumon vert qui
serait la vallée de chevreuse ou des
villes qui ont vocation à y rentrer
comme plaisir ville pour les clés qui
sont vraiment des voisines très proche
donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui la question
c'est est-ce que nous pouvons porter un
autre projet pour cette ville nouvelle
et un projet d'ouverture sur ses voisins
et ses voisines un projet qui ferait de
la casse qui vraiment un phare de
développement pour le département
justement puisque vous évoquez ce
dossier de l'intercommunalité je vous
propose de regarder ce reportage qui
concerne justement plaisir villepreux et
les clés ce sont trois communes qui ont
dû s'allier là aussi le mariage n'est
pas toujours facile puisque la mère des
clayes-sous-bois n'a pas vrai le maire
des clayes-sous-bois n'a pas vraiment
envie de relier rallier cette
intercommunalité il y avait une première
réunion est fière de cette communauté de
communes la mer des clés et et elle
présente réponse en images catherine
mulato patrick jacques de dixmude
première réunion ce mercredi soir de la
communauté de communes de l'ouest
parisien regroupant les villes de
plaisir villepreux et des
clayes-sous-bois un premier conseil y
regarder de près car depuis l'annnonce
de la constitution de cette
intercommunalité la ville des quais sous
bois s'y opposent véronique côté millard
la mer était pourtant bien présenté hier
soir mais pour demander le report de
cette première réunion communautaire
arguant du fait que la mairie n'a pas
été avisé assez tôt de la tenue de ce
conseil et quelle n'a pas reçu les
différents comptes rendus des réunions
préparatoires réunions auxquelles la
mairie des clayes-sous-bois ne s'est
d'ailleurs jamais présenté une demande
de report rejetée par l'assemblée
constituante
véronique côté millard quitte alors la
séance mais promet d'envoyer des
conseillers communautaires
on comprendra bien et dans la situation
actuelle discussion n'est pas non plus
envisageable
mais nous nommerons cependant no no 9
conseillers communautaires pour un délai
maximum de deux mois peut-être qu'ils
ont le temps encore de sujet une fois la
séance s'est poursuivie avec l'élection
du président de la communauté de
communes la mère de plaisir a été élu à
l'unanimité comme malté rejet
coleman berger
faut regarder l'avenir les plus adroits
des cliniciens et des villes provient on
n'est pas là pour faire ce genre de
guéguerres intestines on sait même pas
si demain nous serons là puisque les
élections municipales donc écouter
soyaux calme et en signe d'ouverture
malgré son absence véronique côté
millard a été élue vice-présidente la
communauté de communes de l'ouest
parisien devrait au complet en principe
se réunir en mars prochain pour voter
son budget une étape importante qui
devrait donner lieu à de nouvelles
passes d'armes oral entre les maires de
ces trois communes
valérie pécresse très rapidement il nous
reste à peine deux minutes pour terminer
ce journal je voudrais votre réaction à
ce sujet aujourd'hui véronique côté
millard vous me dites quoi la raison de
refuser cette intercommunalité non mais
ça montre l'absurdité de la fermeture de
saint quentin en yvelines et la
nécessité que la caisse qui bascule à
droite parce que georges lapierre
communalité le hdl existe les trois
villes ne demandent qu'une seule chose
c'est de venir dans la caisse qui elles
sont c'est absurde c'est hors tabac
augmente surtout c'est de ne pas aller
avec plaisir mais non mais ce plaisir
ville pour les clés c'est tout petit
c'est une intercommunalité qui est
tronqué c'est une intercommunalité qui
n'a pas vraiment de sens alors a du sens
quand elles pourront entrer dans la
caisse qui est cette municipale est un
moment décisif la caisse à droite et au
centre et je compte sur tous les
électeurs pour se mobiliser pour cet
enjeu est là très rapidement même si le
sujet prêter être plus développée je
voudrais juste revenir sur cette
information du parisien vous répondiez
ce matin à une interview et vous avez
précisé rien ne justifie l'aide au
transport pour les étrangers sans
papiers vous vous exprimiez en tant que
chef de file de l'opposition la région
ile-de-france pourquoi un tel discours
est ce que cela veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
vous voulez aussi séduire les électeurs
à droite de la droite non je crois qu'au
contraire celle aveuglement de la gauche
vis-à-vis des réalités du quotidien qui
fait le lit des extrêmes aujourd'hui un
francilien de quelle que soit sa
nationalité qui est en situation
régulière qui gagnent plus de 8000 euros
par an n'a pas la gratuité des
transports un étranger en situation
irrégulière et bien lui c'est pas un
dispensaire dans l'espoir d'être
nationale mais non les deux élections
justement sipa le mandat l'an 2000 et
c'est justement à partir de ces
injustices que nourrit le vote extrême
et ben moi je ne veux pas nourrir le
vote extrême je ne veux pas l'injustice
tarifaire si moi je veux que la loi soit
respectée et qu'elle donne des avantages
merci valérie pécresse d'avoir été l
invité de cette édition d'aujourd'hui je
vous rappelle donc que ce soit il ya
l'inauguration du vélodrome on en
parlera dans notre journal de demain et
puis il ya également ce concours bébé
cadum avec cette yvelinois qui se
présentait il n'a pas réussi à
l'emporter les réactions et du jury et
des parents de ce petit timothée
duchesnay ce sera dans le journal de
demain qui vous sera présenté par
catherine mulato excellente soirée